Ok, so we’re set up right?
Is that right?
Yep
Um should we?
Should we test this out visually?
How does this look?
Looks good.
It looks really good.
Today’s order, and more or less the rules
of which every team has been given is 30 minutes
total.
So 20 minutes of presentation and 10 minutes of discussion, question and answer
Tilt it
Let’s go the other way
This way?
Yeah
Well, no.
No, no.
You know it’s a little bit tongue in cheek
of the idea of the event horizon, its kind
of like...its not the party at the end of
the world, but its kind of like the summer
warm-up and this idea of this like unknown
event that’s going to take place.
Ryan stayed up late last night
I stayed up pretty late last night, so I apologize
for any of the like free speech that comes
out.
Sometimes you make things and then when you
look at them you’re like ‘wow I can’t
believe I made that, that’s a little bit
outside my comfort zone.’
But I guess that’s the whole point of doing
competitions like this is you find things
out about yourself you didn’t quite know,
so…
Look at this cutie
The project, essentially is knitted light,
and embodies a co-produced materiality between
people, individuals and a collective group,
and the way that they engage with the project
through adaptive and responsive materials
and changing programs that shift from day
to night.
And so it was really important to me in the
context of the presentation to have a number
of ways of expressing that, and so virtual
reality allows for a really immersive experience.
So sorry, tell me again?
So the two buttons on the side here will allow
you to move around.
Right.
And if you click the trigger it’ll change
from day to night.
If it’s about seeing something new, and
making a statement about what YAP is in its
18th year
Yeah
There is really only one choice.
Yeah, I agree.
You wanna call for a vote Sean?
Alright.